Stay optimistic!
If you want to achieve success as an entrepreneur
you have to stay optimistic that it’s going to work out.
Because life is going to throw you curve balls
you’re going to make a lot of mistakes
you might lose a lot of money
you’re going to have the #LITTLEMAN in your life
tell you all the reasons why your idea’s not going to work out.
You need to stay optimistic that it will.
One of my favorite stories is of Walt Disney.
When he was a little boy his father beat him regularly.
That was his form of, I don’t know
getting rid of some aggression.
But he took it out on his son Walt.
And at a really young age Walt started drawing
and doodling.
And his life at home sucked
and instead of getting down on himself
he remained optimistic
and created this fantasyland for himself
where he imagined he was playing and living.
When he got a little bit older the war was on
and so he joined the army.
He went and he was an ambulance driver in France.
And all he saw around him was people
with their limbs being blown off
and blood everywhere and just misery.
And he was the ambulance driver, right,
imagine how much bad stuff you see every day.
And he remained optimistic
and he wanted people to be happy.
And so how do you be happy if you’re being picked up by an ambulance?
And the little touch that he added was he would draw cartoons
and sketches all over his ambulance of happy creatures
and people having a good time
to try to uplift people’s spirits.
He remained optimistic even in the hardest circumstances.
He came back to America and he wanted to start his own business.
He wanted to be an animator.
He wanted to create his own creations and share it with the world.
And it got so hard for him that he was in Kansas City
and he couldn’t afford to have an apartment anymore
so he slept at his office.
He lived at his office.
He ate cold beans every day
because he couldn’t afford real food.
But he remained optimistic that it was going to work out.
And then finally,
finally after all this crap that happened to him
after all these failures
and not seeing any momentum or success
he finally has something thing that takes off
and it was Mortimer the Lucky Rabbit.
That was his first creation
that really had this commercial success.
And he made the pivotal mistake of agreeing
to allow the copyrights for
Mortimer the Lucky Rabbit to go to his distributor
and then his distributor cut him out of the deal
and he lost his first creation.
And instead of getting down on himself
he remained optimistic.
He thought it was going to work out.
And he thought back to the times
when he was in Kansas City
in his office sitting on his cold floor
and there was a pack of mice
that were always hanging around in his office
and one of them became a really
close friend of Disney
and he treated him as a pet.
And so Walt Disney said, “You know what, my next creation
I’m going to make it a mouse.”
And it became Mickey Mouse.
He remained optimistic,
he remained positive that it would work out
and eventually it did even though he got pounded
and beat down and got screwed over
and saw such terrible things in his life
he remained optimistic that it will work out.
One of my favorite quotes that Disney said
just shortly before he died was
“I hate to see downbeat pictures.
I know life isn’t that way and I don’t want anyone telling me it is.
So stay optimistic
and believe that it’s going to work out.
You guys liked this video, give it a thumbs-up below.
You can click on the link in the description to support me.
Leave a comment. Let me know what you think
and click on my face to subscribe to the channel.
Thank you so much, I’ll see you soon.